قتلت احلامى اقرب وصف للسان حال الطفل
اليمني امير الذي بترت ساقه نتيجه رغم
الحوثي وهو لم يتجاوز عامه الرابعه كذلك
هنا في محافظه تعز ترك لهم الطفل امير
شريف العامري اسيرا للاعاقه بعد ان تسبب
في بتر ساقه ولم يكتفي بذلك بل قتل عمه
وابن عمه شريكا اللاعب حينها
متعوره
هذا وابن عمه
انتهى على طول الاب
دخل الشضايا الى داخل البيت انتهى على طول
وهنا صبايا وبين الم الاب وحسرته على
معاناه طفل
ان تضع هذه الالغام في طريق الاطفال
والنساء والمدنيين في رحلتهم اليوميه لكسب
رزقهم
من الجرائم الحرب لانه انت داري في هذا حي
سكاني اطفال ونساء وطبعا الماء ولا اكثرهم
معاهم اغنام معتمدين على الحطب ضروري ما
يخرجه
هذاك الطريقه
[موسيقى]
الف خير
وبينما يد الحوثي تزرع هذه الالغام هناك
يد اخرى تنزعها تتمثل في مشروع مسام لنزع
الالغام في اليمن الذي نزع منذ انطلاقه في
يوليو 2018 وحتى نهايه العام الماضي نحو
380,000 من الالغام والذخائر غير المتفجره
والعبوات الناسفه